[MUSIC]
Anne, welcome to the GSB.
We are so excited to have you here for
View From The Top.
>> So excited.
>> Great, well, before we start,
I want to do a quick poll.
So please raise your hand if you
have done a 23andMe test before.
Wow, okay, you have a strong
market base here at the GSB.
>> But there's a lot more that could be.
I see, no, I see opportunity [LAUGH].
Love to survey at the end to see how
many people are going to get it now.
>> [LAUGH] So
I have done 23andMe, as well.
And I just wanted to ask you one
question about my test results.
>> Okay.
>> So-
>> [LAUGH]
>> I do a lot of customer support [LAUGH].
>> So should I be concerned that
my results said that I have
92% more Neanderthal DNA than the average
customer, what is that about?
>> That is a fun fact that you
should share at all parties [LAUGH].
It's actually, the Neanderthal
report is kind of an example
of some of the things that we've done.
Where we try to make genetics, and frankly
try to make all of science relatable,
make it something that's fun for people.
So honestly, one of the first things,
I was at a TED dinner once and
we were talking about, there was Craig
Venter, all these famous genetics people,
and they were talking to
a bunch of tech leaders.
And they were talking about the latest
results in one area or another.
And then I brought up
something about asparagus and
how you can smell it in your pee.
And 45 minutes later, people were
still talking about the asparagus and
the pee question.
And I realized people want scientific
information that's kind of fun,
kind of the cocktail party conversation,
and something that's interesting.
So Neanderthals was absolutely
one of the interesting parts.
It teaches people about science.
And then it does become one of those
things that people are always comparing.
I have so much Neanderthal,
what does that mean?
And what should I do about it?
So it's interesting.
But no,
it's a proud fact that you should post.
>> Okay.
>> Widely on everything.
>> Thank you, thank you.
I hope you can all find your-
>> I think that's why you got in [LAUGH].
>> Yeah, actually I think so, thank you.
[LAUGH] Well,
since we're already talking about 23andMe,
I'd love to dig in a little bit more.
So I'm amongst, many of us here
are amongst the 12 million users.
And I'd like to take us back to day one,
actually.
How did you convince that initial set
of customers to buy a DNA ancestry kit?
>> Well,
we didn't convince very many people.
[LAUGH] We had, I'd say one of the things
that's great about 23andMe, and that was
also a shortcoming in those early days,
we're incredibly strong on the science.
And I had two scientific
co-founders from Stanford,
who had just finished their PhDs.
And they had joined, and we created,
essentially, the product we dreamed of.
How can I peruse my chromosomes and
look at all the different reports and
see what they mean and explore?
It was kind of academic fantasies.
And we have a product now
called Ancestry Composition.
In the early days we had these PCA plots,
and
it was relatively technical and
hard to see.
And we thought it was all great.
And so we didn't know marketing research,
at all.
So from a business school perspective,
we did not asses market demand.
We just kind of made the hypothesis,
of course, everyone wants their genome,
of course everyone's
going to want to get it.
So it was, academically,
very interesting and it was controversial.
So we were the front cover,
we were above the fold front page of
The New York Times when we launched.
Amy Harmon wrote the article.
It was the only time New York Times
has ever written sort of
a first-person account
of them doing a product.
We were on the cover of Wired,
Thomas Goetz wrote that piece.
So we got tons of coverage.
And the first day we sold 1,000 kits.
And after that,
it trickled down to 10 to 15 kits a day.
And we didn't have any marketing team.
We just kind of assumed it
would be word of mouth.
It was $1,000 and the value
proposition was not clearly there.
It was really sort of an academic product.
So that was kind of the first
moment in the company we were like,
we might have to do a little bit
more product market research here,
to figure out what's going to drive sales.
But I think the first customers that we
got were really people who are sort of
the quantified self-world,
the people who just want to
test themselves on everything.
And I would say, there's a market of
50 to 100,000 people who are just like,
I want to try it all.
And those were the people
who were coming our way,
who happened to also
have the spare $1,000.
But it was pretty brutal,
the first few years.
>> Yeah, that's very interesting.
And so now, you found product-market fit,
you found all these amazing customers.
>> Well, I would say we're still
finding product-market fit.
I mean, I think what's interesting for
me with genetics, and
I don't know healthcare,
it's so interesting because GSB,
you guys have founded so
many amazing companies.
And the tech world has
really come from here.
And there's all kinds of areas that
have been really revolutionized.
But healthcare is this last frontier
that has not really been evolved.
And the reality is,
it's not just like it's this frontier.
It's kind of like
a different solar system.
Healthcare doesn't
operate in the same way.
We all use healthcare, but
none of us are the customers.
You're just the means for
generating revenue, but
somebody else is paying the bill.
So it's really challenging to change.
And it's also incredibly fragmented.
So in the tech world, when there's
a new technology that comes out,
it's usually rapidly adopted.
You look at what's happened with
machine learning, and TensorFlow, and
all these things that Google puts out,
it gets adopted relatively fast.
And the human genome was
sequenced 20 years ago.
And I would say, how many people have
had their doctor recommend that they
get their genome and use it outside
of pregnancy or outside of cancer?
It's almost none.
And so
part of the issue we have right now,
is genetics has still not been
adopted by the existing system.
And there's all kinds of laws for
that reason, though.
So for instance, doctors,
there's no profit motive for
people to get this information.
So a doctor does not make money
if they give a diagnostic.
And so there's good things about that.
You don't want them excessively
recommending, but for that reason,
as well, no one is really motivated
to create extra work for themselves.
So when I think about product-market fit,
there's still this huge chasm between,
I have lots of consumers who
are frankly really eager to do more and
take more ownership of their health.
But the healthcare world's really
not set up in any capacity
to help them execute on that.
And so,
doctors are not trained on genetics,
doctors are not used to people
coming in with more information.
And frankly prevention is not
a reimbursed part of medicine, it's not.
Figuring out how you can exercise or
how you should eat better is not
something that you get from your doctor.
You get that on your own.
But frankly, that's a huge component
of all kinds of prevention.
So we're still working on
product-market fit, and
how you actually create a new industry
that frankly is direct to consumer.
And how you're inspiring people to take
more ownership of their own health,
but it's also an out-of-pocket expense.
Yes, I think that's a very humble answer,
you have [LAUGH] 12 million customers,
which is amazing.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And I'd like to talk about those 12
million, because obviously selling
kits is one part of the business, but
then when you have these
12 million plus customers.
There's a swath of data, of course,
that comes along with that,
and massive opportunity
in the therapeutic space.
So I'm curious as you're moving
to focusing really on that data,
what gets you excited about all that data?
>> Well, I mean that for me,
when I think about starting the company,
that was a huge part of my incentive and
my dreams.
I find it fascinating that all of
life comes from a really simple code.
So for those of you who are engineers or
coders,
it's mind-blowing to me how
remarkably simple, you have an A,
C, G and T, and that accounts for
all of life on this planet.
And it's small variations, you, and
all of us are 99.5% the same,
and I always tell my kids,
you're 50% banana, and you're 90% mouse.
So you're very similar to everything.
It's remarkable to me that we
don't understand this code.
So I think about, every night you go to
bed and your body just, everything works,
you live in this incredibly complex
system, and we have no idea how it works.
To me, this is the ultimate puzzle,
it's really, as a kid,
it used to just keep me up at night,
how does it all happen?
And even things like how all of
your cells can differentiate, and
how they turn out,
it's mind-blowing to me.
So by having a large amount of data,
we're starting to understand
what does the human genome mean.
And you have some really simple examples.
So for instance, one mutation causes
whether or not you have dry earwax,
or wet earwax,
another really fun medical example.
But the reason why we put out the dry
earwax and the wet earwax kind of report,
is because it teaches people.
That you can have one simple
genetic variation, and
that can cause a different phenotype,
a different trait.
And so what's really interesting for me,
is by having almost 13 million people,
and billions of data points,
is that we're starting to make
sense of the human genome.
And frankly, this should translate one
day, when you have billions and billions,
it should translate one day,
is how you actually really
understand the code of life.
And that's really for me the ultimate goal
here, is like you want to understand it.
And when I think about drug discovery,
my background when I was investing
on Wall Street, was in biotech.
And biotech, it's amazing because
the science is so interesting,
but from an investing perspective.
There was one well-known investor
who's like, I love biotech, he's like,
90% of everything fails,
I just short it all.
And [LAUGH] that's true from
an investment perspective,
there's some reality to that,
statistically, most it's going to fail.
But for me, it's like I want to
create things that are going to work,
I want to create things that are actually
going to have an impact on people.
So if you start with human genetics,
you are more than twice as
likely to be successful.
So one of my hopes here was,
to bring structure and
a new kind of approach to drug discovery.
So more of those drugs
would actually succeed.
And again,
I think about my dad's a physicist,
we mentioned my dad's particle physics.
My dad used to always complain,
he's like, you biologist, it's so
confusing, you're such a disaster, it's
all over the place, there's no structure.
And there's some truth to it, it's really
complicated, and physics has its laws and
its principles.
So for me, that's part of the goal,
is in some ways once we have enough data,
how do you bring enough structure so that
then you could really have very rational
drug design, and actually be able
to have a much higher success rate?
>> One unique aspect of the data
that you have is there is a self
selecting aspect to it.
A lot of most of the data that you have is
people who have signed up for the kits.
So, how do you think about that
when you're making pretty large
generalizations, potentially,
about the data that you have?
>> Well, we get this a lot about,
what's our bias?
And again, coming from Wall Street and
looking at all clinical trials, and say,
I've never seen a data set
that doesn't have a bias.
So it's not bad that we have a bias, the
important thing is to know what it is, and
to be able to identify it,
and then you account for it.
So I would also say now that we are so
large,
we have pretty amazing representation and
diversity of all types
within the data set.
And that was part of the push we had for
10 million, at 10 million
you get a lot of statistical power to
do analysis on most disease areas.
So there's absolutely always a bias,
because we are self selecting,
as people who are paying,
lowest entry point is $100.
But we do attract people for
very different reasons, and
I would say the Ancestry customers
which also do consent for
research coming in at
a lower price point and
are also interested in a different type
of product than my health customers.
So I would say again, my main thing is
with data is it's important in some ways
just to go for size, size really is
the number one thing that matters.
And secondly is really
understanding your limitations, but
not like there's no such
thing as the perfect dataset.
>> Right, well your intention around
women, and other disadvantaged groups, and
getting data around them is so important,
because there are not enough medical
studies done on women and
people in other groups.
And so is that something that
you think about as well as.
>> We do, we think a lot about,
I mean most genetic studies have been
done in European populations, so
that's one of the other things.
We are still majority
European within 23andMe.
But the fact that we are 20,
30% of 23andMe is non European,
that makes us the largest in the world
of non European genetic studies.
So there's things that we can do,
that absolutely will attract and
encourage certain populations to come in.
And I think that's something that's more
and more of a priority for 23andMe is to
make sure that we're attracting
not just a European population but
a very broad population.
And just to emphasize, I think people
don't realize, in some ways studying
Africa is one of the most important and
exciting opportunities in genetics,
because there's more diversity in Africa
than there is in the rest of the world.
And so there's going to be a tremendous
number of really interesting genetic
insights that come from there.
So we're reaching a point, there's
been all kinds of challenges before,
with the complexity of studying
different populations.
But we're getting to a point
where we actually really have
that opportunity to do a lot
more in every population.
And we think about ourselves
even as we put out a report,
how do we hold ourselves to a bar that
we're not just putting out content for
a European population, but putting out
content for all different communities.
>> I'd like to go back to what you
were saying about marketing, and
how it wasn't initially a huge focus.
And in 2013,
you unexpectedly got a note from the FDA
to discontinue marketing of the tests.
We do a lot of crisis management
case studies here at the GSB and
I'm curious if you did, who was your first
call and what advice do they have for you?
>> Good question.
I love, so it's definitely one of the
parts when I speak at Rob Siegel's class
it's like one of the key things.
I love him asking the students like was it
Silicon Valley arrogance or ineptitude?
>> [LAUGH]
>> I love always hearing people talk about
us and I just did another talk,
the innovators dilemma where also,
there was really this sense is like,
you were so inept.
[LAUGH] And so, what people don't realize
on 23andMe, we did get a warning letter.
Mom was proud because it was one of
the most well read warning letters ever.
[LAUGH] It was definitely, and
partly it was it was an unusual warning
letter because it was so angry.
What's interesting is when
23andMe was started like I said,
we were very academic.
And one of, because we were academic, we
actually had Joanna Mountain who came from
Stanford, she was
an assistant professor here.
We had an IRB, we thought through a lot,
like we engaged with ethics like
Hank Reilly who still doesn't really
love us, but we engaged with him.
I come from an academic background,
I love debate.
Like tell me more, what can I do?
Where am I wrong?
So, we totally engaged.
And one of the first people we
had called was David Kessler,
who was the former commissioner of the FDA
so he's like clearly very experienced.
He was a professor at UCSF and
he pulled together his whole team,
like his senior advisors from when
he was in the administration.
And we sat down and
we're like are we a medical device?
And we really debated this.
Like it was a whole debate with his team,
like what are we, and
concluded we're not a medical device.
And in those early days,
it was kind of a question.
Like you have the right
to own your genome.
Like it's your data, like same way you
have a right to look in a mirror, that's
your image, you have the right to have it,
so you have the right to have your genome.
And in my mind all I was doing
was connecting you to publicly
available literature that
seemed totally reasonable.
So in those early days,
we conclude we're not a medical device and
then we even met with people like
Von Eschenbach who was actually the FDA
commissioner at the time and he was super
clear you are not a medical device and
we will not be touching you and
regulating you.
And one thing that was kind of
a political wake up call and
just a company wake up call is
that when Obama came into office,
that changes everything, and
the leadership of the FDA changed.
And they said, no, you are not
outside of our reign of regulation,
we are going to regulate you.
And so it was an overnight kind of shift.
Like we had just been told for years that
we were not going to be regulated and
then it became very clear like you're
not just going to be regulated,
like were coming now.
So, I got the letter on a Friday and
then I had the weekend to sort of
think about it and my typical stance.
I was like, it's not such a big deal.
[LAUGH] And then they made the letter
public, and Kessler called me.
And he called me and
he said Anne, I know you, and
I know you're not paying attention.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And
I'm telling you now that it's a big deal.
And it was, the company really had to
pivot and I had no shortage of people.
Like there was a article Fortune
row called 23 and stupid.
I had no shortage of people,
like well known geneticists who are like,
it's time for you to step back and
let us clean up your mess.
Like no shortage of people who love to
come and be like the woman with no degree,
I was really screwing up the industry.
And I had one really great mentor,
and it was a regulator also a woman,
who said any of two choices,
like do you want to sell the company?
I was like no.
She was like well, then, you put your
head down and you just do the work.
Get the work done, she like but
am telling you now,
it's going to take you five to 10 years.
And we were lucky because we had cash,
we had that ability, I found amazing
leader to do it, and frankly,
it was the best thing for the company.
because I think one of the most important
things 23andMe has proven out is that
consumers actually can
get genetic information.
And most healthcare providers I would say,
tend to assume that you're not capable
of changing your behavior or
understanding complicated information.
And we have now successfully
really proven out that you
can understand really complex concepts.
And we had to prove to the FDA
that at a certain grade level,
over 90% could pass actually tests.
And we had to prove that with our
reports they can do that and we did.
And we now have six,
seven FDA authorizations.
We're the only ones who have
gone down this whole path.
And I feel like when I think about us as
advocates, one of 23andMe as an activist
brand, like we are advocates for consumers
and proving out that you are far more
capable of taking care of yourself than
the healthcare system today believes.
>> And as you've just described,
healthcare is obviously
a heavily regulated industry.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And
many of us will be going into other
heavily regulated industries whether it's
healthcare or FinTech or what have you.
I'm curious, obviously you had
some great conversations and
some great points of contact,
but what was the best and
maybe worst advice that
you got around regulation.
>> Was, interesting the night before.
Like the night before I got my FDA
warning letter I was actually at
a healthcare political dinner,
I wouldn't say which group.
But it was like a group and they were
like, Anne you're getting so stale,
you should do something more crazy.
And I just want to say that was
a group of healthcare regulators, etc,
who were like,
you gotta keep pushing boundaries.
And then the next day I
got my warning letter.
So, clearly that team was
pushing in the wrong direction.
I mean, look,
I think the number one thing that,
the best advice we got when
we had our letter was,
you're on the right side of history.
And so it's just a matter of time.
So one thing I remind people in the
company is that when we started 23andMe,
gay marriage was illegal.
So, the world does change.
So, and it changes because of advocacy,
because of people rising up and
also because of data.
So when people ask,
how did 23andMe convince the FDA?
We convinced them with data.
We went head to head with their
arguments and we're like,
we're going to prove out that we
are accurate, that people can get it.
So, I think the most important advice for
people is knowing that whatever
the laws are now or whatever
the regulations are, things can change.
And society is constantly changing, but
you have to put together the right kind of
package, and the right data, and
the right support to drive that change.
But it's totally mutable.
>> One obvious big societal change in the
past three years has been the pandemic.
And I'm curious how COVID-19
has informed your strategy for
how 23andMe can engage in
potentially future health crises.
>> Well, I think what was interesting
during the pandemic is because we have
millions of people who are consented for
research who are part of it, Very rapidly,
we were able to put out
a questionnaire to customers and
collect hundreds of thousands.
And now I think we have like 1.5 million
people who've taken our COVID survey.
So very quickly we were able to actually
do research on why are some people
getting so sick,
why are some people not getting sick?
Even now I'm kind of fascinated,
there must be genetics,
some people must be genetically resistant.
And you see that with things like HIV.
HIV there's actually a mutation where
people are resistant to getting it.
So we have the ability to very
quickly survey millions of people and
get information about them.
So in this DNA, it's like it's
kind of remarkable that there's no
nationwide surveillance system for
public health.
And we have that ability
now to really do that.
>> Another aspect of COVID that changed
how leaders interact was I heard a lot
of CEOs having text chats or email
exchanges with other business leaders.
And I'm curious how you potentially
leaned on other business leaders and
what kind of maybe business
community that you formed?
>> I mean, in some ways,
it's been kind of nice like I never had
really the CEO business community before.
But I feel like there's now
where I do see more CEOs and
we all have kind of that same pain
point of like, it's really hard.
And specifically right now it's really
hard, it's a really tight job market.
So people all want a lot more money.
And they return to office is
super complicated, is it hybrid?
Is it in person?
Everyone wants something different and
then the stock market
has really collapsed.
And so there's just a tremendous
amount of uncertainty.
And also how do you develop
culture in a Zoom environment?
You can't, you all saw what it was like
going to school in a Zoom environment,
it's not fun.
And so having your office be a Zoom
environment is also not fun.
So, I think it's super complicated,
so like right now it is fun.
It's kind of relieving with
other CEOs to be like,
none of us really know what to do.
And so [LAUGH] there's comfort when we
all have that pain of, it's hard and
all the market dynamic,
everything is about being redefined.
Work environments are never
going to be the same.
And so how do you really
have a hybrid environment?
So that's been the number one thing
I think for me and even at different
policies, talking to companies about,
what are you doing for return to office?
Are people coming in?
How do you manage vaccinations?
Everything has been sort of
non stop of helping manage.
And then also we've had all
kinds of social unrest.
So, also then how do you
manage George Floyd?
And now you have Roe versus Wade,
all of political issues are also
now really rising up to
really occupy people's minds.
So how do you actually
also have a company and
in the background have
such political issues?
So I do think that as the world's
gotten more complicated,
there's been more bonding over,
it's complicated.
>> Yeah, so much of what we learn at
the GSB is around collaboration and
doing projects together and everything.
So I think it's really nice to hear
that that continues even when you're at
the top.
>> Yeah, I mean I think it's
important to always reach out.
And I have to say LinkedIn is
amazing in this capacity, it's so
easy to connect with people now.
And it's so
lovely to go across industries.
So, I do think that people
are particularly interested.
It's so dynamic right now.
People are particularly interested
in hearing different viewpoints.
So I do think it's like
a particularly receptive time.
>> You mentioned company
culture briefly and
every single guest that we've had on
stage has talked about company culture.
>> Yeah.
>> It's obviously very important.
And how were you intentional about
setting the culture at 23, I mean?
>> Well, I had coming from Wall Street,
and again I lived in Wall Street during
like kind of the craziest era,
99, 2000, most of you probably
don't remember this but it was really
>> Wolf of Wall Street.
>> Yeah, for sure [LAUGH] I mean,
there's experiences when I see that or
even when I watch billions.
I was like subparts of billions
are based on real experiences.
There was one episode I was watching I
was like, I remember when that happened.
And they got down to
the specifics of specific trades,
like trades and information,
it was a totally crazy time.
So in some ways, having that experience, I
learned a lot of things of what not to do.
And I have one boss who is in jail.
>> [LAUGH]
>> [CROSSTALK]
>> Okay.
>> And I always say it was like, well,
there's no better way to experience
what not to do, then, leaving that.
And I had another boss who would get so
angry and would slam phones into the wall.
And so
it was also an interesting time watching
Google start and Google being really fun.
It was super supportive,
it was really quirky.
They hired my sister
when she was pregnant.
People wore whatever they wanted.
They were always rollerblading.
Sergey and Larry were always
rollerblading into meetings.
So it kind of opened up the door,
I do credit them.
They opened up the door for
having different types of cultures.
And I've never been
a person who likes veneers,
I have this issue,
I really hate things that are fake.
And I don't like commercials for
that reason and I don't like a plastic
office place where everyone's dressed
up nicely, I feel it's a veneer.
So having a culture that was
authentic was really important to me.
And having a culture where people felt
really comfortable and you had diversity.
We're a genetics company,
we support diversity.
The world is amazing because of diversity,
so we want to support diversity.
And I realized this with myself is,
you hire extraordinary people but
extraordinary people are not
extraordinary every day.
And so we're a team and so for
that reason, if you get sick,
someone can cover for you.
Or if you're just having a bad month,
it doesn't sink everything and
people don't get mad at you,
we are a true team.
And so I've always wanted to have a
culture where we have extraordinary people
but it's truly supportive.
And we have this diversity and
kind of an academic environment you're
always learning,
you have this humility of I know nothing.
I still do say it feel like I know
nothing, I'm always just trying to learn.
And I look at my scientists and others,
that humility is just so important.
So, when I think about culture,
it was really about authenticity.
And like truly supportive and
supportive, really,
if I want to hire people and
have them with me for 10 or 15 years,
you have to be flexible with
like work life balance.
You have to be flexible as
people have other issues.
So like a real balanced environment and
one that hire
humble people who are super
eager to learn from each other.
And for that reason, I have really great
marketing people who know nothing about
therapeutics, and therapeutics people who
know nothing about CAC to LTV like that,
it's so interesting to learn and so
I always tell people like join 23andMe.
And you should take advantage of
the fact that you're constantly learning
really interesting different things.
So culture for
me I think has to be really intentional.
And I think it's really important for
me to have a positive culture where
it's supportive, and I'm really proud
of like the number of people who have left
23andMe and gone off to start companies.
And especially a huge number of
women who've done it and they,
again also are really focused
on creating a positive culture.
So it spreads.
>> Is there maybe
a little specific norm or
practice that you think represents
the culture well, something you guys do?
>> We're very focused on exercise.
So I never dress like this.
It was like a big debate for
me, do I wear my shorts?
So I wear shorts, T shirts and
my running shoes every day.
And I totally terrorize
people who take the elevator.
And I [LAUGH] wanted to put up the signs.
There was a study that came out about hey,
you're sitting in the elevator but
if you had just walked up those stairs it
would have added 30 seconds to your life.
So, I just think for me exercise and
health for me, it's walk the walk.
We have good food, it's healthy,
we don't have soda,
we encourage,
we have lots of fitness classes.
I have a huge number of people, we have a
very intense workout culture, people love.
So we have intro to working out and
then more of the advanced.
We have lots of yoga.
I do lots of yoga meetings.
We'll put the notes on the floor and
then you'd downward dog and
you'd read your notes.
[LAUGH] Hold on one hand, you're in plank.
>> I mean, I think you can-
>> Like balancing.
Yeah, you can be super creative with that.
I think a hallmark of our
culture is the authenticity.
You can be you and you don't have to,
there's no veneer that
you're trying to put on.
And the best thing about being authentic
too is you make mistakes all the time.
And then people frankly, I think,
trust you more when you make mistakes.
>> Yeah, absolutely.
Well, so many of us here are in
healthcare, but many of us are not.
So I'm curious, from your perspective,
what is a trend in healthcare today
that we should all be aware of?
>> Well, I think the trend that's hard
to ignore is the rise of virtual.
So when I first went to Health 2.0
It was a scary set of companies.
I mean this is probably 12, 13 years ago.
It just was not starting yet.
And it was just not starting yet.
So now, and even pre-pandemic, we used
to meet with all kinds of companies that
were virtual pharmacy or virtual
telemedicine and it was such a niche.
And 23andMe had talked about,
should we get involved in these areas?
And I was like, [SOUND] the last thing we
need to do is pioneer another whole path.
But the reality is pandemic
made virtual a requirement.
It's overnight,
you had to start using virtual care.
And pharmacies and laws change.
So, I mean,
there was an incredible opportunity,
this is an example where regulation really
changed and it opened up a huge sector.
So virtual is really interesting.
The thing I'd point on is almost
all of these virtual companies
are focused on employer and
health plan based care.
And that to me always feels odd.
If you go and you join Amazon for
two years and you're prediabetic and
you have a program, why do you lose access
to that program if you change jobs?
Why your health care is with your
employer really doesn't make sense to me.
So part of what we've always tried to
do is create a world that's outside,
that you control that's
outside of the system.
And I would say then other
trend is that more and
more is truly going towards
your own empowerment.
There's an act called 21st Century Cures
that empowers you to be able
to get access to all of your health
records and move them around.
And they're not making it fully easy yet,
but it's coming,
where you should be able
to own all of your records.
But there's also now price transparency.
There's really interesting companies now
surfacing that you can actually know if
you need to go and get a mammogram,
what does it cost?
So in the past, I would call around and
try to get direct to consumer pricing for
something and it was impossible.
And now, it's actually these laws
are in place, to actually force it.
So I'm a huge proponent.
I think there's really exciting
direct to consumer worlds.
And most companies are still focused on
employer or the Medicare populations,
but I would say that there's a huge
opportunity on direct to consumer.
And it's just harder because I
think there is a real shift that
people have to get educated on.
And I think one thing again,
just to emphasize on healthcare and again,
privacy is top of mind for lots of people.
People don't realize that if your
insurance company pays for you to
do a procedure or something, they then
know that and they own that information.
So if you don't want your physician or
your insurance company to know something,
then you should self pay.
And so part of again like 23andMe I always
say is proudly not HIPAA compliant.
Because it actually forces us to get your
bill consent, versus like HIPAA now,
frankly, even I'm always
criticizing Stanford for this,
you don't have a way of opting
out of their HIPAA form.
So that means they can take,
I just went to a doctor the other day,
and they mandate taking your picture and
you have to sign a consent form that
they can do anything they want with it.
Really?
Can you imagine that if Facebook's like,
I'm going to take your picture, and then
I have the ability to do anything I want
with it and you have to consent for that?
That's outrage.
So I do think people,
privacy, and healthcare,
people don't fully understand it.
And you have GDPR and the California
privacy act that's happened for
the tech companies.
But I think there's going to be
a change at some point in healthcare,
people just haven't woken up to it yet.
But there's like a really
terrifying world of how everything,
all your health information is shared
that you just don't know about.
>> That's very helpful advice.
And speaking of advice,
[COUGH] half of us in this auditorium
are actually graduating in three weeks,
including myself.
>> Wow.
>> And many of us have been considering or
are going to be pivoting their careers.
You've pivoted a few times and I'm curious
what lessons you have to share with us.
>> I think pivoting is
the best thing ever.
I think it's so
interesting to learn different areas.
I don't know if you knew Larry Lessig,
who's used to be at Stanford who ran like
Internet law and he was just one day,
I want to learn about corruption and
he moved to Harvard and he's like, I'm
going to become an expert in corruption.
It's so great, to do the same thing
all the time, it's just boring.
So to do totally different things,
the world is so interesting, you should
absolutely keep pushing yourself to just
keep pivot and do interesting things.
I always encourage, I mean,
I try to keep most people at 23andMe, but
when someone's actually been there for a
while and they want to try something else,
and be like, yeah,
you should quit and do something new.
The world is so interesting,
never shortchange yourself on going and
exploring.
You guys are all super, I mean, it's an
amazing talent pool, everyone can go and
get interesting job.
You owe it to yourself to go and
have that exploration of totally
different types of careers.
And frankly,
I feel grateful to my parents who,
when we graduated college, there was
no push to go and get a single job.
So I worked as a nanny, I temped, I worked
in all kinds of different random areas.
And all of those experiences were super
helpful of knowing what you really want.
And even obviously, Wall Street
was just a short term for me, and
I think I'll be at 23andMe for a while.
But I have this luxury of, I'm always
doing different things with 23andMe,
I'm now in drug discovery more.
And then personally I do all these real
estate projects at home in Los Altos,
that's super interesting.
So I totally encourage, keep pivoting,
and every experience adds up.
And you never know when an experience
is going to be valuable,
and if it's not interesting, then quit.
>> Great, well that was definitely
an answer I needed to hear.
>> Yeah.
[LAUGH]
>> So thank you.
>> Definitely.
>> [LAUGH] Well, thank you Ann,
I deeply admire the conviction that
you've had throughout your entire career.
And I know all of us here
are excited to see how you and
23andMe will continue to change the world.
And I have more questions, but I know
we have some questions in the audience.
>> Okay.
>> I'd like to turn it over to them.
>> Great.
>> Hi, my name is Neil Rands, I'm a
medical student and business student here.
And I'm curious how you think about
balancing data privacy, patient
privacy with sharing information in
a way that advances scientific progress?
>> I love the privacy questions,
because again,
I think that what I found
is that most people
actually want to participate in research.
So when we started the company,
it was sort of hypothesized,
people don't actually want to
participate in research.
It was almost this mindset
of a clinical trial.
Get them to come in and
consent for everything,
because you never know if you'll be
able to really get anything else.
And I looked at things like
Susan G Komen and Livestrong and
all this enthusiasm to do walks.
People really actually
want to make a difference and
even bone marrow drives and such.
And I go again to some of these
human subjects consent forms,
where they don't learn information
back to individuals, and
frankly I find them super insulting.
It's the paternalistic side, you think I'm
not capable of getting this information?
And just to level set with people, there's
a JAMA study from I think 1960 where they
asked physicians whether or not they would
tell a patient that they had cancer.
And 90% of physicians said they
would not tell their patient.
So the world has really evolved and
it's come a long ways and
I think it's kudos to
the medical world for evolving.
But I think that we can absolutely
do more with looking at individuals
as a responsible individual who
can handle their information and
more as a partnership.
And so right now, a lot of healthcare
providers and insurance companies and
Epic, they all use HIPAA as a way to not
let a consumer share their information.
There's always these concerns, a consumer
might get their medical records and
then accidentally share it in the wrong
way, do the wrong things with it, or
it might be too much information for them.
There's kind of a very
paternalistic take on it.
And I've just always felt you should
be entitled to your information.
And then put it on the individual,
if you want to share it in your ways,
like allow you to share it.
So to answer your question specifically,
I think that there should be transparency
and I think there should be choice.
That's the hallmark of everything 23andMe
does, is I'm fiercely independent and
I never want someone
telling me what to do.
And the last thing I want someone tell,
my health care provider should
not be telling me what to do.
Give me the information and
I will make my own decisions.
And 80% of our customers
opt in to research.
It's not even they have
to click out of it,
they're electing to opt in to research.
So I would argue that,
even more people would opt in to
research if it was given a choice.
And that was kind of my
point with Stanford,
why aren't I giving a choice of
actually opting in or opting out?
Why do I have to be part of it?
And so I do think that choice and
transparency is actually
how you build trust.
And I think a lot of consumers
actually really want to be part of it.
But also one more thing
I would put on you is,
people should have the right
to know the results.
So if you participated in the study,
tell people what came out of that study.
Most people participate in a clinical
trial and they have no idea what happened,
isn't that crazy?
Again, I find it totally insulting,
don't treat me like a human subject,
treat me like a partner.
>> Hi, I'm Harshit and I'm from India,
I'm studying, business here.
I want to understand how you have used, or
maybe how you have insights from
genetics on racial inequality?
>> I mean, looking at diversity,
I mean, so
it's a question there's lots
of complexities your question.
I would say a couple of things one,
when we started 23andMe,
we never expected that we're going to
be in the dialogue about race.
We got into it for research and
all these things and
suddenly we're about redefining race.
We absolutely can see, we had one
really interesting publication where we
asked people the definition
of African American.
And you can see how people in the South
might have 10% African DNA and
they do not identify as African American.
And you have people in Seattle who
have zero percentage African DNA and
they identify as African American.
So even defining what you are and
your environment where you are,
it's super complicated.
So there's absolutely aspects
that I think 23andMe can
have an impact on by helping
understand genetic ancestry and
likelihood to respond to medication or
likelihood to have an issue.
So for instance, there's someone
named Carlos Bustamante at UCSF, and
he does phenomenal research in
the Latino population and asthma.
And he has seen there's certain
medications that people should never take
in the Latino population,
but why are they prescribed?
And you have another
example where in Hawaii,
the state of Hawaii does not
allow the sale of Plavix.
Plavix, again, is a well known as
an anti-clotting drug, and it's because so
many people in the state don't
respond to the medication.
So I think one way, again, it's racial and
health inequity is a huge issue.
But I think one thing that you can
actually start to do is really understand
not racial profiling people, but really
understand your genetic ancestry and
what the mutations are that you have.
And then whether or not you have
a predisposition for a condition and
should you be managed in a different way?
Or whether or not you have
a predisposition to not respond or
likely to respond to a medication.
So I do think there's a ton of
opportunity to have improvement.
And again, racial profiling's only,
it's the last area where it's
acceptable is in healthcare.
It's the first line of every medical
record, 45 year old white male comes in.
It's not something I think that we
actually really have the opportunity
of changing.
Hi, how's it going?
My name is Jammas.
Like Neil, I'm also a MD MBA student.
>> I love it.
>> And I worked in a Huntington's disease
clinic for a year before medical school.
And a lot of times the genetic results
that they would get was some of the most
devastating news they could
ever hear in their entire life.
And how would you respond to people
who believe 23andMe should have a more
thorough informed consent process
before releasing information like BRCA1
mutations, for instance?
And then do you foresee a future
where people might push to have
patients act on some of
the information they receive and
how are you preparing for that,
once those treatments are available?
>> So again it goes to some of
the paternalistic questions.
I think that you can absolutely have
a great informed consent online.
And I think that's the kind of
thing that's like,
it should not be a debate,
it's about data.
Generate data where you ask people to fill
up the online consent and then you ask
them to go through counseling, and
then you have them answer those questions.
Can you understand it?
So we've done a lot of work about,
are people understanding
what they are getting?
So I would argue that having
an online consent and
making sure is potentially even better.
So for instance, 23andMe,
you go through a number of consents.
You can't sign up accidentally,
it's a hard process.
Reports like the Alzheimer's BRCA for
breast cancer are behind
an additional layer of consent.
So you have to click through and
there's a video that talks
about what potentially happens.
There's all kinds of resources about, hey,
here's the information you might learn,
this is what to expect.
And we see people pause on health.
And not everyone wants to know health.
And to your point on Huntington's,
the information is real.
It's meaningful for people.
But Huntington's is a slightly
different story because you
can't do anything about it.
Verses in BRCA, at a certain age, you can.
You can find out that
you are high risk and
get a prophylactic mastectomy and
ovariectomy.
And we've seen people, we have thousands
of customers who have now gotten this.
And we can see that 20 to 30% of
our customers never would have
qualified under existing
insurance guidelines.
So I would argue that healthcare
has huge limitations because
we have not enabled broad access.
And so saying that you can't get this
information until you have a one-to-one,
in-person kind of interaction,
only puts up barriers to access.
For me also, the fundamental premise and
actually learn this,
I would spend a lot of
time investing in India.
Healthcare will never be accessible
to all if it's dependent upon
a one-to-one interaction.
That right there should be a good
concept for all of you to run on.
You can't really improve care for
people unless we find ways to
automate it more and more.
And so that has to happen.
In the first company I ever invested in,
talk about things that were too early,
it was a pap smear company
called Neuromedical.
And it was one of the first AI
companies that I had ever seen.
It was back in 1996.
And they would take pap smears,
the majority of which are normal, and
they'd run them through the machine,
and then they would isolate,
here is the top 20% that we
need a pathologist to look at.
And the company got taken
down by the pathologist.
How dare you automate our job?
But the reality is,
you can't have scalable solutions
in healthcare if you don't
have automation in some ways.
I ask my kids sometimes, all of you here,
you probably don't remember.
When I was little and
I wanted to book a hotel in Paris,
I had to set my alarm, and wake up and
call, and talk to a human.
That's how it worked.
And now we're all totally spoiled.
You go online, you can just book,
it's all automated.
We never talk to people.
And so, healthcare has to go more and
more in that direction.
And then save the really
expensive precious resources for
people who really, really need care.
>> We have time for one more.
>> Hi, I'm Brianna.
I'm a geneticist and
actually a law student here.
And so talking about privacy and consent.
The thing that's different about genetic
information is, it's not just about you,
it's about your family.
So how do you think about your
responsibility for community consent or
familial consent, and community and
familial understanding of
the data that you collect?
>> Yeah, that's a great question.
And it's a huge complexity here.
So we have gone with the hypothesis,
it's your DNA,
it's your right to learn about yourself,
but there are absolutely consequences.
And so, for instance,
your mother might not want to learn
that if she's a carrier for BRCA.
And you could get tested and
find out that you have two copies.
And therefore it's 100%
deterministic your mother has it.
And we've seen that instance.
And we see this, I would say,
what's interesting, again,
I love all the MDs in here, and it'd be
super fun, we should chat more later.
We don't get lots of consternation and
concern about health reports.
Our customers, we find,
are mostly, they're okay.
A BRCA report is not fun to get, but
they can handle all this information.
And we've proven that now in spades.
The part that no one anticipates is that
their parent is not their parent, or
their sibling is not their sibling.
If you have access to
your genetic information,
you're going to learn things
about your entire family.
And so I don't think that there's
a realistic world of group consent.
I think the reality is,
you own the right to your own body.
But we absolutely try to educate people,
that your information has consequences.
But I would say, no one ever thinks it's
them that is not related
to a family member.
And we have an additional consent form,
that is just always a surprise for people.
But it's a very real and
very tricky aspect of 23andMe is that,
you're not just related
to your immediate family.
This whole room is genetically connected.
And so, any number, you would probably
take some percentage of this room and
kind of connect everybody.
So I totally real and that's, in some ways
there's the inspiring part for research.
In that,
we really are all in this together.
So if you want to solve the mystery of
the human genome, and you want to solve
the genetics of various disease, and
what does it really mean to be well,
it is within the power of
all of us coming together.
But there's absolutely has to be some
of the ethics, and the consent of,
how are we actually all getting together?
And that's what I said, in Stanford
there's a lot, again, Hank who is,
again, engaged with us quite a bit.
But there's really interesting
questions around this, around ethics.
And that's why, again,
I'm eternally grateful to Joanna Mountain,
when she came from Stanford, she was
absolutely a thought leader in ethics.
And when I always think about
the difference between 23andMe and
other companies like Facebook,
didn't start with a consent form.
I know they have a research team and
other things, but
there's no consent that's part of it.
23andMe from day one, had consent and
engaged with ethicists and
really thought through, and
recognize there's consequences.
But in some ways, the guiding principle
for 23andMe is transparency and choice.
And whether it's transparency in yourself,
it's choice, whether you want to get your
genetic information, choice if you
want to participate in research,
choice if you don't want to
do all these things.
And I think that's one of
the issues I have in healthcare.
Is most times you're not provided choice
and you're not provided transparency.
>> Well, thank you, Anne, for
your leadership and your wisdom.
And thank you all for coming.
That concludes View From The Top.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]